il attendait ça avec impatience les
footballeurs peuvent à nouveau fouler
leur pelouse de nombreux clubs amateurs
ont repris les entraînements des
retrouvailles entre coéquipiers après
deux mois d'arrêt le groupe l'ambiance
tout ça ça manque ça manque beaucoup
on va devoir les amis tout est fermé
donc forcément de se retrouver comme ça
le dimanche c'est top ça fait du bien
déjà de retrouver les copains de
retrouver l'esprit d'équipé faire un
petit peu d'activités physiques et
sportives en collectivité parce que
faire tout seul pendant confinement
s'est pas forcément très agréable
les horaires ont été adaptés selon les
clubs en raison du couvre-feu pour lui s
jouy en josas c'est un entraînement le
samedi matin et un autre le dimanche de
14h à 16h au programme des exercices
sans contact on verra aussi comment
comment la situation sanitaire évolué
puisque on peut pas jouer encore
complètement à part au contact par aux
oppositions c'est c'est quand même un
manque aussi pour nous le foot permet
col de faire des exercices sans contact
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de gamme comme
on peut le voir derrière voilà malgré
même si on fait pas de match à la fin
c'est pas grave au moins on s'est
retrouvé au 9 rue ballons quoi les clubs
avancent malgré tout à l aveugle sans
visibilité pour le reste de l'année on
en était à quatre matchs joués sur huit
normalement donc on a eu quatre matches
annulés déjà et on a une poule de douze
donc il faut au moins onze matches aller
pour pour terminer la phase aller et il
ya 22 matchs en tout sur toute la saison
et la saison se termine officiellement
le 30 juin
donc après on peut plus continuer de
faire la saison s'arrêtera le 30 juin
quand il arrive l'équipe espère au moins
finir la première moitié de la saison
pour l'instant de solution semble
privilégiée par la fédération française
de football avancer de manière
traditionnelle en essayant de jouer
autant de matches que possible ou bien
scindé les poules en deux afin
d'organiser des plus petits championnats
dans un système de playoffs et play down